now the number of chrono virus cases
globally has crossed a four million with
the u.s. accounting for more than a
quarter of them and former President
Barack Obama has described Donald
Trump's handling of the pandemic there
as an absolute chaotic disaster
Obama said this in a conference call
with former members of his
administration which was leaked he added
that the current administration appears
to have a mindset of what's in it for me
and to heck with everybody else
the US has reported about 1.3 million
infections and more than 77 thousand
deaths
Eric Hamm is a US political analyst and
has written a book on the Republican
Party he says the comments by President
Obama may have been strategic we're
talking about a former president
speaking to about 3,000 of his former
employees people who work for him in the
White House people who understand
acutely how important it is to keep
things in word and the fact that the
president made such biting comments
about the current occupant of the White
House you one has to suspect that the
president actually wanted these comments
to get out the question is why would he
want them out and why would he want them
out now given that the United States is
confronting this virus this pandemic
knowing that the president certainly
will attack and again you Americans are
still left really trying to basically
fend for themselves as the pandemic is
reaching now upwards of 80,000 people
and the number of deaths that have been
caused by this virus President Barack
Obama is attempting to do at this moment
in time right now is to unify the
Democratic Party and to also signal not
only to those who work in the
administration but also to those as you
mentioned who may be who may be on the
fence right now who may be not ready to
actually get behind a Joe Biden's
candidacy I think what the former
president is doing is signaling that he
is working for the Democratic nominee
and that he needs everyone on board and
he's making it clear that he too will be
working as he said and as it was leaked
he will be working as hard as he can
to elect Joe Biden in the fall